bonjour à tous bienvenue sur ma chaîne
youtube je suis avec lui de négoce le
mec tu en arrives à [ __ ] de bruxelles
après une pré non tu m'appelles par la
communauté ça fait partie fans s'appelle
ludovic on espère que vous allez bien à
nous clairement bamoussa la moyen âge un
peu malade dans son bas les couilles
voici tout de suite maintenant ce que
vous allez voir sur la chaîne youtube si
le premier épisode d'une série qu'on a
créé ensemble s'appelle le talisman qui
a été entièrement réalisée par ludovic
aux primaires c'est plus de oui oui
c'est vrai que j'ai réalisé cette petite
série fantastique car fantastique
c'est le genre petit jeu de mot l'escale
est fantastique et en même temps est
fantastique mais oui c'est ça raymond
devos qui sort de sa tombe
ça fait un an qu'on travaille sur cette
série on a commencé les syndics turler
vraiment un ans nous a pris beaucoup
beaucoup de temps parce que c'est un
projet très ambitieux que le bon norman
a bien voulu financer à boîte la manche
un pigeon en fait alors avec sur youtube
se vend mal et des vidéos qui sont
sponsorisés qui sont financés par des
marques stars qui pousse les projets ça
c'est cool est là c'est vraiment une
vidéo que j'ai financé moi même c'est
vraiment mon initiative c'est un projet
artistique en indépendant et pas
beaucoup de fictions sur youtube
enfin il y en a mais c'est toujours
assez délicat c'est ça se consomme moins
facilement que des vidéos de
divertissement à dire donc voilà
pourquoi on a pris un petit peu de
l'islande en c1 espère que ça va vous
faire qui fait évidemment en compte sur
vous si vous aimez vous mettre des
pouces en l'air pour donner de la force
à j'ai des petits commenté par les
voiles permettent à gueuler les gens
pourraient profiter du premier épisode
non oui c'est ça alaibe abobo avons
profité bon visionnage les sony
[Musique]
il
papillon n'est la voilà au plus haut
voilà ça vraiment mes petits enfants
chéris
je vis mes derniers instants il me reste
peu de temps à vivre
à peine une minute 25 aux morts avant de
disparaître
je vais vous léguez mon héritage gas vu
que je me suis embrouillé avec toute la
famille
j'étais site et qu'il reviendrait à vous
deux je ne sais pas trop comment m'y
prendre c'est la première fois que je
leur dis mais vous vous souvenez de mon
château de campagne et celui à vendre
portes de vente
eh bien j'ai décidé de vous le léguer à
je vais donc partager ça en deux quoi
tient sans vladimir la clé du château
non
merci de vie et pour toi nathan le
porte-clés à fallait pas on peut quand
même y mettre jusqu'à cette clé a quand
même bien tu verras nathan dans les
moments difficiles de ton existence
je suis sûr que ce porte-clés ce sera
utile
ce papier j'ai aussi 15000 euros sur mon
compte bancaire
ils sont pour vous sophie blanc vous
avez pris bien soin de moi ces deux
derniers jours
merci monsieur charest annonce peut-être
une erreur non jeu
[Musique]
pardon je suis désolé je suis pas trop
dans un moule frites là parce que en
fait il est là j'ai perdu mon grand père
il ya deux heures en mer de quel âge il
avait 85 ans merde moi tu as et c'est
marre on la vire suis moi je m'en bats
les couilles tu vois j'écoute sur
samurai depuis une semaine et j'en fais
pas que toi pataquès plus tard tu vois
même les clients sont furieux contre toi
[ __ ] mais en plus ils ont dit non tu
as même pas rangés les plateaux dit
coupez les tomates même timéo fait mieux
parce que toi alors qu'il est en stage à
4e et aveugles voient ça comme c'est
beau il a su saisir la beauté mon visage
et le retranscrire sur une pièce
d'agneau timéo tu continues comme ça et
dans trois heures je transforme ton
stage d'observation en cdi le manager
voilà monsieur votre kebab sans oignons
merci beaucoup
on va pas être facile tous les jours
c'est pas évident avec courage en tout
cas je suis de tout coeur avec vous
merci
mais c'est quoi ce qui émane de merde
vous avez vu couler toute l'année vous
avez chier dedans vous avez ruiné ma vie
c'est un incompétent
bon là manifestement tu sers à rien donc
ce que tu vas faire c'est que tu vas
prendre ta journée tu vas rentrer chez
toi et tu reviendras tu serais jamais ok
avez vous la carte de fidélité comme
s'il avait réussir à vendre des kebabs
sans moi alors que justin vais je passer
une journée de merde alors nathan j'ai
un petit truc à te dire je sature nathan
j'arrive plus je n'en peux plus tu prend
aucune initiative temps drôle tu as une
basse si je suis responsable de sortir
les poubelles le matin déjà gelé pas
fait mais je suis responsable de le
faire 1
après avec quoi il va quoi déjà il y
avait un truc il faut déjà fait la
vaisselle et edf
tu les a appelés ouais non non mais
j'allais le faire mardi matin tu fais
quoi là boomi demi tu vas ou bep bts
c'est encore impeccablement et toi on va
où enfin j'ai perdu mon grand-père la
mama qui tu es ils ont découvert un obus
datant de moins 3000 avant jésus-christ
jusqu'à présent le dernier recensé daté
de 2950 loïc je te parle d'un truc
perçoit là tu m'écoutes où tout emballé
comme excuse on attend je suis désolé je
l'écouté pas je suis dans mes recherches
tu disais quoi moi mais voilà j'ai perdu
mon père que ça fait chier ils ont
réussi à fabriquer un composites plus
légers que l'air c'est incroyable moi
j'ai toute ma gueule quoi là je te parle
sinon il y a des gens qui lisent ici au
mercy vaste et je suis seul et free roam
et condoléances
peut-être avec gti qu'un proche de ton
grand père georges robert ouverts dont
le voyage a tenu à nous réunir une
dernière fois tu vois pour nous dire au
revoir a eu un héritage non non j'en
avais moi sur votre compte dans black à
tous et a surgi un petit truc je me suis
même pas d'héritage mexès c'est qu'on
imaginait un porte-clés nick ridicule on
dirait un jouet kinder maxime bon tu me
connais je m'en fous pas matérialiste
attente c'est l'intention qui compte
[Musique]
oui ok ce que ton grand père t'a donné
en héritage c'est pas un porte-clés
c'est un talisman
talisman renault talisman non on attend
un vrai talisman et je pense pouvoir
trouver son mode d'emploi dans un
grimoire
d'après ce bouquin que je viens de lire
intégralement ce talisman permet de se
balader dans les dimensions interne
hâtive de notre réalité doit être
content mais je ne comprends pas pour
faire ça il ya une infinité dimension
chacune forgé par une infinité de
possibilités offertes par le monde
depuis les débuts de l'humanité
mais je sais pas ce que tu fumes mais ça
a l'air énorme je veux goûter ont par
exemple dans une dimension des parents
ne se sont jamais rencontrés débat
n'existe pas ok et pour ce faire il
suffit de serrer le talisman dans les
mains et de penser à une dimension et
[Musique]